[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
disaster film called the core
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins in boston massachusetts
three enthusiastic business people get
ready to go into a meeting as soon as
they walk in one person falls
unconscious
simultaneously many people pass out dead
throughout the city and several
accidents take place at the same time
meanwhile at the university of chicago
dr joshua josh keyes is teaching
students about sound waves his lecture
is interrupted by two men in black suits
who insist he come with them josh is
confused but agrees anyway they get him
on a jet and bring him to a facility in
washington where josh meets his old
friend dr serge levesque
serge is a nuclear weapons specialist
and was urgently called to the facility
they are taken to a morgue-like place
with many dead bodies and are greeted by
lieutenant general thomas purcell the
lieutenant informs them that all the
dead bodies have the same date and time
of death by the clue josh instantly
guesses that all of them had pacemakers
inserted into their hearts the duo is
here to help them figure out what caused
the pacemakers to stop working the
lieutenant assumes that it is the result
of an electromagnetic pulse weapon but
josh assures him that it cannot be
possible
meanwhile in trafalgar square london
many birds start falling dead on the
ground while others randomly launch at
people and buildings
some time later josh and his co-worker
friends watch the news about the event
on tv josh finally realizes that the
deaths of the people and the bird
attacks might be related to the earth's
magnetic field he asks his coworker to
get a hold of any other similar bizarre
events happening around the world josh
then gets on his computer hoping that
his theory is wrong
somewhere else in outer space major
rebecca beck childs and commander bob
iverson are ready to land the space
shuttle endeavour back on earth when
they enter the atmosphere a magnetic
instability causes them to lose
connection with mission control then
they notice the shuttle's line of launch
is wrong and it is about to crash land
beck quickly makes some calculations and
changes the course following her
calculations they land into the la river
avoiding any property damage or loss of
life
meanwhile an earth specialist named dr
conrad zimski is approached by josh he
presents his ideas to zimski who
condescendingly asks him to meet at his
office
later josh explains about the magnetic
field to him but an arrogant zimski
claims it to be false although zimsky
acted like he didn't care after josh
leaves he brings out a secret file and
calls lieutenant thomas to tell him
about the discovery meanwhile josh and
serge are at a bar talking when they are
interrupted by the guards again they
take the duo to a conference where
high-ranking officials concerned with
the matter are called zimski presents
the discovery as his own and asks josh
to explain it to the panel josh uses a
half-cut peach to represent the earth
and explains that the earth's inner core
has stopped spinning for an unknown
reason this means that the
electromagnetic field around the earth
will soon disappear which will further
expose the earth's surface to unfiltered
solar radiation josh uses fire and a
peach to show what will happen to the
earth in a few months the lieutenant
asks for a solution and josh replies
that there isn't one however zimsky is
adamant about finding a way to restart
the planet the group immediately flies
to utah to meet dr edward braz brazelton
braz shows them his invention called the
ultrasonic lasers which can create holes
in any dense rock using this technology
they can create a hole through the
ground that will lead them to the
earth's core lieutenant thomas offers
braz all resources he needs to create a
ship that will take them to the core
they plan to set off nuclear charges
into the earth's core to induce force
that will rotate it again while inducing
the charges is not that difficult
traveling to the core is the team's
biggest problem
somewhere else fbi agents meet a hacker
named donald rat finch they take the man
to the lieutenant and the team rat has
been recruited to control the flow of
information on the internet and prevent
any information about the mission from
being circulated meanwhile beck and bob
who managed to land the shuttle safely
earlier are praised for their quick
thinking the lieutenant walks in and
assigns the two to accompany josh serge
zimski and braz on the mission
some days later a conference is
organized to declare the official
initiation of the mission beck meets
josh and her team members for the first
time josh is declared the head of the
mission much to zimski's dismay he
starts narrating the preparation period
that will go on for the next three
months
first braz and his team of experienced
scientists will manufacture the first
ever ship that will be capable of
reaching the center of our planet the
ship will be a multi-compartment vessel
called the virgil zimski is responsible
for calculating the scale of the
explosion needed to restart the rotation
of the core
beck and bob will pilot the ship while
serge is in charge of initiating the
nuclear reaction three months later the
ship is almost ready the members train
and prepare themselves for the mission
during this time josh and back start to
harbor feelings for each other before
the team can start the mission an
aggressive thunderstorm starts striking
the planet's surface which further
pushes back the mission's deadline the
team finally travels to the south
pacific where the ship virgil waits for
them they board the ship after getting a
green light from mission control and
virgil finally takes a dive into the
pacific ocean
they are welcomed by whales swimming
alongside them in no time the ship
reaches the depths the ultrasonic lasers
work their magic and the ship manages to
pierce through the ground after the
first 12 hours the ship has reached 700
miles below the earth's surface they are
currently traveling through the mantle
and are about to enter the empty space
apparently with their three months of
preparation this team of the earth's
best scientists had not taken the space
into consideration so they brace
themselves for aggressive turbulence
the ship then enters an area full of
purple crystals unfortunately for the
crew the ship is stopped when one
crystal jams the ultrasonic laser the
only way to fix the problem is by going
out and removing the crystal manually
everyone except for beck steps out and
is mesmerized by the view as braz and
josh cut the crystal that jammed the
laser hot lava starts pouring nearby
zimski quickly runs inside the ship
leaving the others by themselves they
finally managed to cut the crystal that
was blocking the ship but josh runs out
of oxygen and falls unconscious in the
process luckily serge manages to save
his friend's life and brings him inside
bob is outside seeing if the laser still
works beck turns them on and the two are
delighted when it starts working however
just then a crystal falls on bob and
punctures his suit
he falls into the hot lava and dies
beck freezes in shock seeing her partner
fall into a pit of fire she quickly
composes herself and gets on bob's seat
to restart the ship
virgil dives into the molten lava
narrowly escaping the falling crystals
josh regains consciousness and is told
about bob they mourn their teammates
death and are faced with the harsh
reality that they can die at any moment
in their mission it is now the second
day since the mission started josh serge
and braz are in the weapons compartment
when suddenly the ship goes through
turbulence beck advises the group to get
out of there as they will have to eject
the compartment to stop the ship from
malfunctioning the three run outside but
serge realizes that he left his charges
and launch codes in the compartment
without them they won't be able to
initiate the nuclear reactor he goes
inside the compartment and hands josh
the codes but is locked there in the
process to save him josh asks beck to
override the ejection system but zimsky
tells her that the whole ship will have
to face the consequences the life of one
person should not put the life of
humanity in danger hearing this beck
makes the decision to sacrifice serge
eventually serge is crushed and the
compartment is ejected josh cries
watching his friend die through the
monitor
some time later the mission control sees
that virgil is about to finally enter
the earth's core when it does it goes at
a higher speed than they had predicted
beck believes this is a good thing
because they can complete the mission
sooner but zimski figures out that they
will not be able to rotate the core
because of the unexpected density
according to him they should abort the
mission and return to the surface but
the group disagrees regardless he
informs mission control about the
situation and tells them they will have
to abort mission control puts their
backup plan into action the backup plan
is a top secret project destiny or deep
earth seismic trigger initiative the
group finds out that destiny is an old
project led by zimski it was intended to
be used as a weapon by the us
however when it was first tested it
caused the core's rotation to stop
hence zimski and his team were the
reason for the chaos all along but
didn't tell anyone to avoid taking
accountability the scientists believe
that using the destiny can restart the
core but according to josh it will only
destroy the planet further the
lieutenant is ordered to start the
project to destiny and bring virgil back
but josh suggests that they continue
with the original plan and asks the
lieutenant to launch destiny only if
they fail
however zimsky retaliates saying that if
they do not get out before destiny is
initiated they will surely die on the
surface the lack of an electromagnetic
field causes a ripple in the atmosphere
the heat from the sun melts the golden
gate bridge and the surrounding area the
team doesn't have long before project
destiny initiates josh manages to
contact hacker rat secretly and tells
him to hack into the mainframe and stop
destiny from starting josh and braz try
to figure out a way they can restart the
core zimski suggests they create a
ripple effect by changing the time of
detonations they are relieved to see the
simulation of the process is a success
but the group knows that the execution
will not be as easy after reaching 2600
miles inside the surface they finally
enter the innermost core zimski suggests
they eject each compartment with the
nuclear warforce but they will have to
modify the ship's gear to make it
possible the only problem is that to
modify the gear someone will have to go
inside a tiny compartment where the
temperature is extremely high basically
whoever goes in will definitely die
they draw straws to decide who will do
the task braz gets the short straw and
accepts his fate he wears a suit and
hugs his members goodbye before going
into the compartment the temperature is
extremely high but braz's suit protects
him temporarily he successfully modifies
the compartment and completes the
mission but unfortunately dies in the
process
the group does not have time to mourn
his death then zimsky and josh take the
nuclear weapons to each compartment for
them to be ejected back on the surface
the destiny project is stopped when rat
hacks the project's stimulator in virgil
two of the compartments are successfully
ejected but when they are at the third
one turbulence hits the weapon rolls
over zimski's legs trapping him in the
compartment he asks josh to run away as
he stays behind waiting for his death
josh finally completes the mission of
ejecting the weapons suddenly the ship
stops working and josh and beck sit
together awaiting their last moment but
just then josh tells beck that they can
use the heat from the core to restart
the ship
zimski who is still alive in the
compartment laughs hysterically as the
explosion goes off the series of
explosions caused the core to spin again
the mission has finally been completed
and the world is saved however josh and
back still struggle to save their own
lives they finally managed to restart
the ship using the heat from the core
and they kiss enjoy virgil makes its way
to the surface at high speed however
once they reach the surface the mission
loses its connection with the ship they
see its location and figure it is
landing somewhere near hawaii when the
ship reaches the bottom of the ocean it
stops because of the lack of heat to
fuel it
beck and josh can do nothing but wait
for help
many ships are sent to look for the two
but they find no signs of the ship
just then they catch the sound created
by whales surrounding the ship using the
whale they navigate the ship and rescue
the duo it is now a week later rat in a
cafe inserting a cd into his laptop he
plans to share the whole mission and the
crew's bravery with the world the crew's
sacrifice did not go in vain as people
will remember them as heroes who saved
the planet earth
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching